[Musique]
derrière les voitures de course la fête
au centre-ville et les touristes qui
affluent le Grand Prix cache une autre
réalité il y a beaucoup plus de filles
qui affichent sur les sites à Montréal à
la cause du Grand Prix comme une
frénésie autour de
rester pendant un an dans l'univers de
la prostitution elle a connu le week-end
du Grand Prix à Montréal et les clients
on demande spéciale si j'ai terminé ou
si je connaissais une mineure ou si
j'avais l'air d'une jeune femme
s'il pouvait simuler l'agression
sexuelle avec moi c'était toutes sortes
de demandes comme ceux la semaine
dernière et la même reçu la proposition
d'un homme sur Instagram
baby pour environ par semaine
l'approche du Grand Prix on veut éviter
que des femmes et des filles soient
recrutées par des proxénètes qui
cherchent à répondre à la demande pour
des services sexuels
des organismes qui luttent contre
l'exploitation sexuelle lance une
campagne de publicité qui sera visible
dans les abribus et sur les réseaux
sociaux pour rappeler que payer pour du
sexe est-il légal au Canada payé pour un
acte sexuel c'est l'imposer et que les
clients sont à la base d'un système qui
exploite les femmes et les filles le
Service de police de la Ville de
Montréal a visité 80 hôtels de la
métropole surtout au centre-ville pour
demander au personnels de rester
vigilant de nous informer si à leurs
yeux il y a des situations qui semblent
anormales ou qui impliqueraient des
juvéniles on s'occupe surtout en
priorité des juvénels mais il n'y aura
pas plus d'opérations qu'à l'habitude
pour arrêter ceux qui achètent des
services sexuels si on devait mener des
opérations dans chaque hôtel pour voir
s'il y a des clients vous comprendrez
que c'est presque impossible selon
plusieurs intervenant du milieu la
police doit accentuer la répression pour
que les clients cessent d'avoir un
sentiment d'impunité j'ai l'impression
que nous deux opérations clientes très
rapprochées dans le temps peut-être dans
deux trois villes pourraient donner un
signal fort et rappeler l'existence de
cette infraction criminelle là comme il
y a pas de répression arrestation
mais c'est ces hommes là se disent que
c'est permis que c'est pas grave c'est
la norme mais pour les victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle les séquelles
peuvent être profondes et rester
longtemps ici Olivier Bachard
Radio-Canada Montréal